welcome to this video and this is the
3000th blitz game number 3000 on this
channel there are probably a couple of
more in total but from the pure number
we've got number 3000 GM there are a
couple of more blitz games in other
formats but this is yeah this is all
important number 3000 nice so I've got a
semi NIM so he against act or layer Cola
so let's see what I can do against him
yeah got the absolute mainline there is
some also what I recommend for black in
my recently published book and now I
have f5 but it's surprising that he that
he thinks about this not playing a5 is
dangerous here yeah this is for example
rather dangerous I'm like it is not
clear that it is bad yeah it just rather
risky white gets a very straightforward
attack iam here 96 is already close
Teague stakes and 5 yeah just about
holds Queen h5 however is definitely
dangerous threatening 96 no he can go
Queen f6 then he doesn't have to take
okay so now g6 takes takes is made on
edge 7 so he has to go Queen f7 let's do
this first
if I go rugae three now threatening
Queen f7 with maid it's not exactly
difficult to see but it's still
interesting
I believe how has he covered he has to
go aged six I guess okay so what about
this isn't the student made queen aged
seven king f7 Luke every check King
takes g6e takes a five checkmate isn't
that nice for the father chan 3000 scam
I get to get to sacrifice the Queen and
that's very nice yeah you never know
what kind of game you get it could be
something terrible blunder stuff or
whatever and then this is going to be
the game that's really nice okay so
Queen takes h7 let's let's have a quick
chat at the coming checkmate yeah King
has to take we check check this is one
weight very cute one or if he takes here
we replace each X and five mate it's
very nice that's good good fun so I'm
actually think that this is getting a
very dangerous year for black I looked
at this f6 online for my book as well
because I was constantly tried to
introduce lines or recommend lines that
have been somewhat neglected by other
books because it's more interesting to
recommend something new or something
that is not widely regarded as is so
great but here I really had to discard
the idea of playing with f6 because I
felt that it's too dangerous
in a practical game and we we kind of
saw in this in this game here what was
happening yeah after this night g6 is
winning already you know kind of kind of
brutal yeah if he takes it
this is made on age seven Jeff checkmate
another funny funny mate with the king
basically you are being smothered there
by his own pieces so we cannot take he
went here
and now Luke f3y a very straightforward
play with Queen f7 being a threat the
only move that he can play is age 6 cm
and then yeah I wasn't entirely sure
about the move water now if I take first
and then go rook g3 or group g3
immediately now this assist could be
better and because Bishop d3 Bishop h6
is probably going to be working I mean
here I'm threatening to just remove the
bishop with the maid so I don't really
see what he can do if he plays this I'm
can do him and again this is going to be
a maid yeah this image can be a very
entertaining line if you if you get the
this kind of this kind of
straightforward attacking positions yes
so I'm really winning after Knight u6
quite funny yeah I hope you enjoyed this
game and thanks a lot for being a
follower of the channel watching the
Blitz game some some people I know do
that every morning in Europe it's always
9 o'clock in the morning yeah together
with breakfast ok thanks a lot guys bye